imagine the frustration of being accused
of something you did not do take it in
for stopping at a red light motorists
are paying tens of millions of dollars
in speed and red light camera fines with
some calling it highway robbery some
suburbs simply can't quit the cash that
comes from them they're gonna take their
money that they earned all summer and
try to pay that fine not realizing it's
a scam you know those cameras I take a
picture of you and send you a traffic
ticket when you run a red light yeah
thanks to a bunch of Bradbury Skittles
that have come out it turns out they're
literally a scam red light cameras do
not make the road safer in fact they
increase the odds of accidents by 15
from people slamming on their brakes
when they see a camera while the number
of people running red lights stay
absolutely the same we want safe
intersections but there's not any data
that proves that this was making these
intersections safer we're finding that
it's actually become a danger because
people are so conscious of it that
they'll Jam their brakes on beforehand
and as some have claimed that there is a
higher incidence of rear end strikes now
because people are so concerned about
that we don't have any independent
people to check the accuracy of these
cameras and yeah for some reason
politicians and bureaucrats are still
pushing for more and more red light
cameras they say things like red light
cameras hold drivers accountable even
though they clearly do not why are they
so adamant about red light cameras when
the facts say otherwise because like
many things it's all about the money
red light camera industry there is a
shocking amount of corrupt money to go
around let me explain so you're a local
politician your salary sucks but you
want to make more money
the only real way for a government to
make more money is by taxing people more
really Rob profession the problem is who
wants to get tax born the moment you
raise taxes your constituents are going
to vote you out of office so we need
something else we need a sneakier way to
extract those tax dollars without them
thinking that this is a traditional tax
enter red light cameras and speeding
cash too
most innocent of citizens break traffic
loss on a daily basis when I started
going through it I swear it was creepy
because I wouldn't have gone through it
and all of a sudden Boop this is the
first time she's ever got a ticket in
her life I got two tickets for running a
red light violation I got 700 worth of
tickets in here within two months I have
six red light tickets
devastating I personally feel I didn't
go over the speed limit I have a
mortgage I got the gas the light the
phones I mean all that combined together
it just doesn't cut it oh I'm very
frustrated about this I really am in
1999 56 of Americans admitted to Running
Red Lights that's more than half of the
population you could be taxing and at 50
to 500 a ticket that could be tens of
millions of dollars going into your
coffers one billion that's with a B
billion dollars was collected from
Illinois motorists between 2008 and
2018. that's ridiculous in times when
people can't afford more to pay now
we're hitting them over the head with
ticket after ticket after ticket this is
revenue generator period a Rawling money
box and thanks to red light cameras you
can make all that money without the need
of employing expensive police officers
to do the ticketing for you we've made
no secret to the fact we intend to use
these cameras in this kind of Technology
more as opposed to less because when
we're you know looking at scariest
resources namely expensive highly
trained police officers their time is
best used out dealing with real police
work not sitting at some street corner
watching for people to make illegal
turns and the great thing is most
citizens will happily bend over and take
it all you gotta do is say how all of
this is in the name of safety you won't
want any kids getting ran over would you
so even though most people hate tickets
most of the time they end up just
accepting responsibility and paying the
fine anyways once you pay your fine you
essentially admit your liability you
give up your right to contest it you
know you have the right to go in and
challenge it if you want to but once
it's done it's pretty much done and you
want to know the best part since is the
corporations that make these red light
cameras make literally hundreds of
millions of dollars from just one of
these City contracts they are more than
willing to bribe you in exchange for
your supports because remember you the
politician hold the keys to their wealth
so subscribe for more and here's a
step-by-step guide as to how shout out
to America uncover with Chris Chapel for
covering the story first big fan I'll
link to their Channel below now let's
get into it
this is a way of
to me I feel just a way to rip people
off
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
if you've been wanting some truly
wireless earbuds this holiday season to
drown out the noise of your relatives
but you don't want to show the money off
for airpods or other overpriced options
then you gotta check out the everyday
earbuds by raycon when we first got
these in I was pretty skeptical to be
honest I thought there was no way these
things could compete but I was proven
wrong these raycons are an insane value
not only do they sound good but you get
a super secure fit in your ear I was
able to run with these on it's got a
good compact charging case with a
battery level indicator and they have a
really low profile in your ear much
lower profile than my expensive Sony
earbuds you can pick from five different
colors it comes with a one year warranty
and there's a 30 day happiness guarantee
too so pick up a pair for yourself or as
a gift by clicking the link below or
going to buy raycon.com jaketran to get
15 off site why with code holiday on top
of that raycon is having a countdown to
Christmas this entire month with a new
pop-up flash deal for you to take
advantage of every single day so click
the link below now thanks to raycon for
sponsoring this video
[Music]
step one you gotta Guilt Trip the masses
Running Red Lights is deadly red light
crashes kill hundreds of people in the
US every year and injure over 100 times
that amount when a driver ignores
traffic signals they are much more
likely to be in a fatal accident but
despite this lots of drivers in America
still treat red lights and traffic
signals as a suggestion this is about
Public Safety these are the things that
you should be screaming from the top of
your lungs if you want to enact red
light cameras in your city think about
it who's gonna argue with making the
roads safer who would want to get in the
way of something that's going to reduce
the number of car accidents when it's a
matter of safety people are willing to
overlook a lot of things like hundreds
of dollars worth of super sketchy
tickets from red light cameras so even
though the reality is that you're
getting richer with every red light
camera you can just simply say more
cameras keeps the public safe and this
isn't even necessarily fall loss
installing red light cameras has
actually been correlated to a decrease
in fatal red light crashes which makes
it even more convincing even though the
data is not all that black and white now
that you have the masses on your side
now it's time to get the red light
camera companies on your side
[Music]
step two this is where the red light
camera companies come into play they
have a lot of power in this scenario the
camera companies are the ones with the
technology and manpower to install the
devices but remember for a big city like
say Chicago for instance a single red
light camera contract can be worth well
over 100 million dollars and who
controls who gets that contract you
you're the one with the power to open a
whole new city up to their product after
all so they have to make it worth your
while just look at Tony riguchi he was
the mayor in a suburb of Chicago called
Oak Brook Terrace for over a decade in
that time he collected huge payoffs from
a red light camera company called safe
speed he was able to get 88 000 worth of
bribes while he was in power in exchange
he supported the red light camera
company by approving the use of more and
more cameras year after year he even
received annual renewal bonuses from the
company as a thanks for his effort but
here's the problem Tony riguchi thought
too small only 88 thousand dollars
that's chunk change compared to how much
money saves me made off of this deal he
should have strong armed them for a lot
more but who knows maybe he got more on
the side that he didn't plead guilty to
because how much money did these red
light cameras in his suburb make nearly
17 million dollars in the span of just
four years now that's a lot of money for
a local government
so don't be afraid to make a big ask if
they want your business they're gonna
have to comply anyways so ask for the
moon and you shall receive maybe even
shop your bribe offer around to the
other red light camera companies out
there to see if they can give you more
as you see there are a lot of ways to go
about this
patient spend some time crafting the
right bride and once you've brokered a
deal that you can live with it's time to
install those red light cameras and let
the tickets flow
[Music]
step 3 let the tickets flow once the red
light cameras go up it's all just a
waiting game from here on out and at
first the tickets were rolling fast
because people who usually just drive
through the light won't know there's a
camera there until it's too late so
right from the start you're in for a
windfall of cash I got 700 worth of
tickets in here within two months but
after a little time goes by the area's
residents might smarten up a bit they'll
remember that there's a red light camera
there and might actually start driving
safer we don't want that now do we so
that's when you start ramping up
production just like they did over in
Chicago their robotic red light cameras
started experiencing sudden random
spikes in the number of tickets they
were giving out giving the city a whole
lot more money quote cameras that for
years generated just a few tickets daily
suddenly caught dozens of drivers a day
one camera near the United Center
rocketed from generating one ticket per
day to 56 per day for a two-week period
last summer before mysteriously dropping
back to normal end quote as a result
thousands of drivers were charged with
100 fines they did not deserve talk
about easy money and nobody would have
ever known if the Chicago Tribune hadn't
done an investigation into the matter
when Chicago Transportation officials
were questioned about what was happening
all they had to do was play dumb they
simply said they had no knowledge of the
increasing tickets until the
investigative report was released about
it genius right these cameras are like
passive income Dream Machines the only
trouble you'll ever run into is people
trying to expose your plot but don't
worry there are ways to deal with that
too
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
step four negate the facts see some
Studies have found that red light
cameras might be correlated with a
decrease in the number of fatal crashes
but that's not the whole picture in
reality red light cameras actually
increase the likelihood of rear end
crashes by a lot that's because people
tend to stop pretty abruptly when they
realize there's a camera monitoring them
but what do you do when critics start
bringing up this inconvenient fact so
you take a page out of Florida's book in
2018 the Florida Department of Highway
Safety and Motor Vehicles discovered
that there was actually a 15 increase in
car crashes after red light cameras were
installed
and that the number of red light Runners
still stayed the same across the state
in short they weren't working like at
all
when people started finding out that red
light cameras were more about profits
than safety they wanted to ban red light
cameras in the entire State of Florida
luckily the state supreme court was on
the side of the red light camera
companies it ruled that the cameras were
legal in 2019 leading Tampa and
Clearwater to renew their contracts with
their favorite red light camera
companies trustable figures all across
the state voiced their support for the
red light cameras like Daniel Slaughter
the Clearwater Police Chief who said he
believes red light cameras hold drivers
accountable and boom they were able to
keep their money machine running
[Music]
step 5 don't get caught like redflex a
company that used to be the biggest red
light camera vendor in Chicago they were
killing it earning more than 120 million
dollars from the city contract
installing 384 cameras and collecting
more than 400 million dollars in traffic
funds but everything came crumbling down
in 2012 when the Chicago Tribune first
revealed allegations that the entire
contract was built on a massive bribery
scheme at City Hall
just like that redflex and everyone else
involved went down hard redflex agreed
to pay 20 million dollars to the city in
2017 to settle its lawsuit over the
company's admitted fraud Karen Finley
the former CEO of the company was sent
to 14 months in prison and John bills
the city hall manager who oversaw the
entire deal was sentenced to 10 years in
federal prison as it turns out bills was
making up to two thousand dollars for
every camera installed that's almost a
million dollars for all the cameras they
had on top of that bills was bribed with
lavish vacation trips an Arizona condo a
Mercedes and more or more recently in
2020 with the case of late Senator
Martin Sandoval he pled guilty that
taking 250 000 in bribes from the red
light camera company sync speed they
worked together for years he said that
he accepted bribes to service safe
speeds protector in the state senate he
would push bills in the favor of red
light cameras and oppose ones that
threatened the industry's interests he
ended up dying from covet in 2020 but he
was facing up to about 12 and a half
years in federal prison for his crimes
so if you're going to run a red light
scam never start feeling too safe or too
comfortable you gotta stay paranoid
[Music]
step 6 public relations unfortunately
the red light camera industry is slowly
getting exposed bit by bit 11 states in
the country have already banned the use
of red light cameras to issue tickets
altogether that's 11 jurisdictions that
you are locked out of forever and more
are pushing to ban them every day there
are groups whose primary goal is to
abolish red light cameras politicians
are even tweeting about the corruption
in the red light camera industry so we
gotta stop the spread and the way you do
that is with some good old public
relations
you gotta fight back against the facts
with some propaganda
say you're improving the red light
camera technology so that it actually
prevents accidents by delaying green
lights tell them that there will be more
supervision over the whole industry
promise that these for-profit camera
companies will be on their best behavior
from now on anything to squeeze every
last cent out of the public while you
still can
it's pretty sick for City politicians to
scam American drivers out of billions
with traffic tickets but at least
they're not forcibly harvesting our
organs right no seriously that's a real
thing and it's happening right now in
China
China pretty much harvests organs from
their political prisoners whenever they
feel like it and in return they're
making a lot of money from Western
customers I mean just one human heart is
worth 160 thousand dollars in China and
they have hundreds of thousands of
prisoners to harvest from the details of
China's multi-billion dollar organ
harvesting business are gruesome it's so
disturbing that it's actually too much
for a public video
that's why we released it as a private
documentary only available to members of
this Channel and fair warning this might
be the most horrifying private
documentary we have ever released all
you have to do to access this exclusive
documentary and every private video
that's too Twisted for the public is
click that join button below and there's
a refund policy too unlike most YouTube
memberships so if you join and you don't
think it's worth it email us within your
first month of joining for the first
time and we will personally refund you
for your first month after your first
month there is no refund pause the video
scroll down and click that join button
right now
[Music]
foreign
[Music]